justin bieber and frita with this book on the
front line first air email today we are
on twitter
and pippin strike will be painted with
procedural rules and emails
efe live
white
this benefit that significant
benítez in the fig chance to be both
bradley no type of money as and
How does that digital transparency let you feel
because
it scares me, it makes me
think a lot about what I want
to be known about me that I don't and it also makes me
think that if my generation or
those who came before me dreamed at some
point  or they dreamed of being famous, they don't
know what there is, I want to be famous or appear
on TV, sometimes I feel that the
coming generations will dream of
privacy because there will come a
time when I see things
in which privacy  It will be a luxury it
will be a privilege that few
or no one will have
and in the team
who read the clause from start to finish
when I long for on facebook
no one
good
is something noble nor are the institutions  ructions is not the
same
because this
and getting to have only my
experience and imagination
where I live as they say anything
about myths like doing it
because you don't know what anymore and take care of the
authority of who is going to rob you on the
corner or anything not  It is to enter
with that
and online
for a long time
we have had a government that, although it
has not been mentioned as a dictator, has
had these political tendencies of a
dictator but now with the telecom law,
it was an important clear
that people will realize that we
they are watching in some way but
now I was going to be legal as
sure to be in the secular field before
knowing
a programming language is
just learning another language helps
you understand how things work and
you can understand how
surveillance works  or
privacy and protecting yourself
is like the beginning of protection
except if you don't understand the
language how are you going to understand how it works?
Iona, that it is next to learn other
languages, we will have to understand
the language first, which is something that we
should be able to know, all this is a
great step,
I recommend throwing it away. I think that if there are better
tools that are interactive, I will
present the same to you. Executive secure is
something that has worked  and finally they are
the tools that have been most
effective for the care of your
data and your information against
mass surveillance
to data protection for
no reason that comes
to visit us I know but let's see let's
see  the monitors of the surveillance cameras
just don't film the dump
then the days and see if you
don't need to be there anymore you don't open the door
like before or don't leave it open like it
used to happen in mexico
in rhythm beyond being part of  Your
protection in Mexico
will have a certain amount of time, but the one who
wants to kill you, the one who wants to do
something, seeks, seeks, was going to give, and you think
that you think that he would give me  they excited and
secure communication can protect you from
that well it's like it's like your house you
put a key you put a second
cover
you can whoever wants to enter seriously
enters it will cost more work will
save more time but not for that reason
you are going to leave your door wide open
final made in spain time then on
a general level it is happiness to stop
swapping with every day to make sure
joke life
means university they needed
were damages
and performance meters
when I was in law underway when
We learned about the bill in
many compañeros because they began to
mobilize and began to organize
marches.
Look, it says no to censorship, no to the
telecom law, no more power, power was
one of the slogans, it
is suddenly difficult to explain everything
that needs to be  explain what is behind
the law and everything behind the
importance of defending the internet
ah
from live issues
control
a way to escape
completely  established entity
I don't know probably it's not
probably as chema said it's
eventually what we do is the
encryptions will eventually be
decrypted
but I think that doesn't have to be
the stoppage either for not doing
things now you feel and if we don't do something
there won't be  way for this to change
for the better and I think we are just at
that first start and so if there is a
moment to act well at this moment it
is now
at the level of the march I live lakers
alluding to the end spies time